[Musique]
la réélection des libéraux de justin
trudeau sème la grogne dans l'ouest un
mécontentement qui s'est exprimée entre
autres avec la montée en popularité du
mouvement ou exit qui prône la formation
d'un parti politique fédéral qui à
l'image du bloc québécois défendrai
l'idée de l'indépendance des provinces
de l'ouest
ce projet et ce regroupement n'aurait
probablement pas eu autant d lançant
l'utilisation des groupes facebook comme
outil de mobilisation un outil puissant
qui a la cote
mais qui est porteur de risques de
dérapage de polarisation et de
désinformation alors avant d'aller plus
loin dans cette discussion jeff il faut
vraiment faire la différence établir la
différence entre une page facebook et un
groupe facebook
non pas du tout une page facebook bon
les administrateurs publie sur la page
et les gens qui sont abonnées voit les
publications pour commenter mais on
s'est un peu plus passif on on voit les
publications seulement dans un groupe on
peut participer
donc dans la plupart des groupes tout le
monde peut aller publier eux-mêmes et
avoir accès à tous les d'histoire donc
s'il ya cent mille monde en gros les
cent mille membres peuvent publier et
rejoindre les autres tranquillement vers
les groupes peuvent être secret ou
privés donc si on n'est pas membre de ce
groupe l'on peut pas les voir ce qui
s'est créé à l'intérieur il y avait des
groupes qu'on ne peut même pas savoir
qu'ils existent sont n'est pas membre
médias n'a pas toujours existé ça sur
internet des espaces un peu plus
restreint fermée où les gens peuvent
discuter entre eux oui on peut de 3,8
sorte de forum qui vont plaire à toutes
sortes de communautés ça paye des
communautés très très nicher ou des
communautés extremis par exemple mais
c'est dur à trouver
facebook tout le monde est là dessus
dans son fric donc c'est beaucoup facile
de trouver ces groupes là quand on est
sur facebook est aussi facebook fait la
promotion des groupes
l'année dernière le présent facebook
avait annoncé que l'algorithme de
facebook allait favoriser les amis les
groupes plutôt que les pages
donc on donne une plus grande visibilité
aux publications dans les groupes
donc on les voit plus sur notre fil
d'actualité et aussi bien facebook fait
la promotion de groupes parce que quand
on est membre d'un groupe facebook nous
en recommande d'autre et donc je parlais
chercheurs revenus du reste qui est
chercheur à l'université stanford et
elle a commencé à s'intéresser à la
désinformation dans les groupe parce que
je venais d'avoir un enfant c'était
bonnet un groupe pour nouvelles mamans
et facebook déjà commandé des groupes
anti vaccins on voit que la plateforme
nous aide à trouver des groupes donc
c'est pour ça probablement que les
groupes sont devenus de plus en plus
populaires jouets plus populaires mais
aussi c'était ça s'est développé comme
un gros foyer de polarisation c'est ça
c'est que les groupes facebook sont
devenus un peu le haut lieu de la
mobilisation de toutes sortes sur
facebook parce que c'est facile
d'atteindre un autre histoire
facebook a changé son algorithme pour
favoriser les groupes et six mois plus
tard on lui l'éclatement du mouvement
des légendes en france qui était un
mouvement bon citoyen mais complètement
organisées dans les groupes facebook
pense pas que ça on doit gérer la
champions doit fermer la bouche non
j'suis désolé
au lendemain de l'élection il ya un
groupe qui s'appelle vol ou exceed qui a
explosé j'ai jamais vu une communauté
explosion s'est rapidement de 20000 à
plus de 200 milles abonnés en quelques
heures seulement et est ce qui est drôle
c'est que la page facebook qui a créé le
groupe
elle a seulement une vingtaine de
milliers d'abonnés donc on voit que les
gens priorise les groupes plutôt que
l'image est souvent les gens qui publie
le plus souvent que les gens qui sont
les plus motivés et les plus mobilisées
et ceux qui dictent le ton un petit
groupe de rock que les personnes les
plus enragés qui prennent le plus
d'espèces dans le groupe
et là on a l'impression qu'un
utilisateur qu'on veut pas là l'encontre
de ce discours là il ya aussi le fait
que si on fait partie d'un groupe et
tout le monde est d'accord tout moment
la même orientation politique
est-ce qu'on va se signaler les
commentaires qui dépasse un peu les
bornes ça peut donner lieu à des
échanges qui peuvent déraper
par exemple au canada on est le groupe
il ya novès canada qui a qui se veut un
peu le groupe de la mouvance jeu région
on a eu peur de débordements la der des
menaces de mort contre le premier
ministre justin trudeau des discours
haineux là dedans
ce peuple a été montré du doigt beaucoup
pour des discours de surfer les risques
de dérapage au sein des groupes facebook
ne se limite pas aux groupes consacrés à
la politique
maude tremblay le site très bien elle
qui a dû quitter un groupe facebook
dédié à la diète cétogène dégoûté parce
qu'ici écrit mais qu'est-ce qui servait
avec le fameux groupe facebook sur la
diète cet âge un mois là bas c'est
vraiment l'affairé l'a cru aussi mais à
force de voir tout le temps des liens
douteux des sources douteuses des des
théories comme l'oeuf le sucre pose de
cancer ou l'a dit cet âge un verrou le
teillage déry le sait fait tout le temps
tout le temps qu'on peut jamais rien
moi je vais poser des questions comment
disait qu'il ne suit pas les
recommandations du guide alimentaire
canadien peut prendre autant de place
donc je me suis dans un groupe comme ça
avec des gens qui passaient cocotiers
genre vais répondre puisque lorsque je
posais des questions des gens qui
avaient quand même des réactions très
vives parfois même style ça peut aller
jusqu'aux insu c'est comme ces gens là
se sentent menacés quand tu viens
apporter une nuance et que les gens
disent comment ça tu insultes et moi
j'avais pas envie de me défendre qu'en
2000 personnes éventuellement occupe
je pense que c'est jean le cam bon
alignement ce qu'on essaie d'apporter
s'ils sont attaqués ils vont sur la
grille on dit en bonne voie d'islande
dans un groupe facebook qui supporte une
idée donné j'ai changé de look facebook
et je n'attendais que mon énergie au 5
août
le match quelle belle journée à 50 mg le
dimanche c'est justin winx plus à terme
bianca longpré et chroniqueuse
l'humoriste auteur et blogueuse 7 qui
s'est aussi fait connaître en tant que
mère ordinaire et de lancer un groupe
facebook baptisé qe ces corps manche
pour souper et en trois semaines
plus de cinquante mille personnes y ont
adhéré et déjà bien que l'on prie dit en
avoir perdu le contrôle
un groupe facebook oui elle est partie
d'où cette idée non et l'idée que les
gens puissent échanger sur la cuisine
mais de façon un peu plus ordinaire de
temps ils vont pouvoir déposer ceux-là
qui légèrement pourrait changer
ils vont proposer des questions ça c'est
l'idée au départ mais là qu'est ce qui
t'arrive ça a dégénéré ça a été rapide à
moi j'aime y sont allés le premier même
pas 24 avait dix mille personnes sur le
groupe mais rapidement les gens sont à
partager les recettes et les jeunes
n'était pas contraint dé retirer étaient
pas contents de la façon que c'était
fait parce que les gens prenaient des
photos de leur cuisine de leur point de
leurs comptoirs je pensais pas que ça
venait chercher les gens à ce point - là
on parle pas de religion on n'en parle
pas de politique parle de cuisine c'est
vraiment souvent des manières de faire
donc la propreté de son espace de
travail et aussi des aliments qui sont
remplacés par d'autres
par exemple j'ai remplacé du bitume par
de l'associé mais ça se fait pas ça fait
beau dehors ça fait boule de neige à
tous deux continents et gardent bien
j'aimerais pas se voir chez vous tu
m'aimes pas d'avoir des enfants
est-ce que c'est hors de contrôle est
hors de contrôle
ça c'est sûr ça c'est des mauvais mots
de même des menaces des trucs comme ça
ta classe c'est fini a passé des ménages
et derek classe non je vous blog et vous
êtes qu'ikea selon quels critères vous
décidé d'exclure par exemple quelqu'un
est lié par exemple qui font la
promotion souvent des forces
d'informations sur comment perdre du
poids comment guérir le cancer parce que
la cuisine ça fait aussi partie de
toutes les fausses informations sur des
aliments les éléments qui vont changer
ta vie donc un groupe facebook ça peut
être un vecteur de faut s'informer et
non même en même temps cuisine comporte
pas de religion politique la peau de
l'environnement au détriment on parle de
cuisine
il ya plein de fausses d'information par
exemple quelqu'un écrit qu'il est malade
ou qu'ils habitent ils tous les gens
tous essaient de vendre leurs produits
ou de dire que tu es la femme voilée
guérir arrêter de manger qui dit arrêtez
de manger de la viande
annie plus longtemps mark zuckerberg le
fondateur de facebook a clairement dit
facebook aimerait ça que cette
plateforme l'on soit davantage axé sur
les groupes prise mais plus que les
pages
ouais vous en pensez quoi mais c'est des
gens font partie d'un groupe ils vont
s'identifier ils vont être plus souvent
sur la plateforme
donc c'est sûr que pour lui c'est bon
pour nous je pense que ça prend beaucoup
de place dans la vie des gens sûrement
trop un moment donné est pas la vraie
vie quand même dans le groupe facebook
j'ai écrit sur ma page avant d'écrire
quelque chose
réfléchissez ce que c'est constructif
parce que c'est nécessaire sinon on fait
d'autres choses namasté aux webmasters